here's what a show of force looks like
this is what authorities feared a repeat
of this is what they got they're
treasonous lying
september 18th not another january 6th
no storming of the capital here no
chance of even getting close so on a
scale of one to ten when you see all of
this how concerned are you
well we're always concerned but again
you know we're prepared for today so
that's an important thing that we've
prepared we've trained we've done the
things that we need to do
to make sure that our capital is secure
this rally the first since the
insurrection seared on this country's
collective mind not a pro-trump demo
it's not about president trump but
plenty of his supporters if we had
intended to capture this building we
would have been down here with rifles
here to demand fairness this is about
justice
and disparate treatment
for what they call political prisoners
those accused or convicted of violence
and insurrection their right to habeas
corpus has been violated you have the
right to a speedy trial in the united
states it's in our constitution the
security operation here is huge you've
got offices from multiple forces the
national guard here by the washington
monument you've got a line of trucks
parked up to stop anybody leaving a
vehicle there or coming through in their
own vehicle when you walk around towards
the capitol there are three levels of
security three layers you've got two
spaced apart levels offences beyond that
you've got the high fences with razor
wire and then beyond that inside the
capital the police looking out after
january 6th they are not taking any
chances today
on the lawn lots of differences lots of
passion
we're not a danger to anybody
they were described by some as domestic
terrorists but you would say they're not
in danger they're not domestic
terrorists i was here on january the 6th
it was mostly a peaceful demonstration
but there were some people who violated
the law
and they should be prosecuted between
five and 700 protesters were expected
police putting the eventual number of
people here between 400 and 450.
for four months in prison including a
man who knows what it's like to crash
the capital doug hughes landed a
gyrocopter there in 2015 a major
security breach which led to jail time
giving him a unique viewpoint here if
there is reason to believe that a person
is violent or may commit violence okay
then the department of justice has not a
right to the obligation
to keep them in custody until trial
more than 600 people have been charged
so far former president trump who was
impeached then acquitted for incitement
issuing this statement saying hearts and
minds are with the people being
persecuted so unfairly they're being
held
excessively and with midterms and a
possible trump rerun in 2024 this is
unlikely to be the last protest here
phil lavelle al jazeera washington